isn't it nice to stay dry it's not just
us that thinks so surfaces with special
waterproof properties are found across
the natural world all kinds of
microscopic textures trap air at the
surface of materials stopping water
molecules from interacting with them and
keeping plants and animals from getting
wet because droplets of water can't
stick to these super waterproof surfaces
they stretch out recoil and bounce right
off the lotus leaf was considered to be
the gold standard when it comes to
staying dry but now scientists have
found a way to make surfaces stay even
drier with tiny ridges scientists caused
drops to split into smaller drops when
they hit the surface and smaller drops
recoiled faster than larger ones
so bounce off more quickly and the less
time a drop that spends in contact with
the material the drier it stays
this effect helps keep butterflies
delicate wings completely dry and could
also be used to make aircraft engines
which could fly an ultra cold conditions
by bouncing off supercooled water before
it has a chance to freeze